That concludes EHR certification.
The other two components of high
tech are meaningful use and
incentive payments.
Before we discuss them,
we'll have a basic overview of
electronic medical records.
Physicians are in the data business.
They collect data.
They make treatment decisions
based on that data.
And they follow patients through other
data and make adjustments as needed.
The data physicians record can be
divided into subjective information,
generally information collected from the
patient, such as the chief complaint,
the reason they visited the physician
today, their medical history, and
history of the particular problem
that brought them to the doctor.
Physicians may collect objective
data by doing a physical exam,
ordering X-rays or rather images,
or doing lab tests.
The resulting data can be in many forms.
It can be free text.
It can be structured codes,
such as the ICD we referred to earlier.
Could be continuous wave forms
from an electrocardiogram, images,
sound recordings, or even videos.
Increasingly data from
chronic disease and
other patients may be coming from
their smart phone or from physiologic
measurement devices they use to
track their own health at home.
Storing and presenting this rich data
set is an EMR design challenge, yet
many EMRs still mimic the organization
of the paper chart, even simulating
the tabs that divide the sections
where the data types are stored.
Despite its key role in medicine,
physicians have historically focused far
more on collecting the right data than
they have on recording it completely,
accurately, and legibly.
As we've seen, in a fragmented system
of care where many physicians treat
aspects of a single patient's care,
this can lead to duplicate testing or
even errors.
Here's a particularly dramatic example.
For which medication was
this prescription written?
What is Isordil, Plendil,
or are you not sure?